Kim Kardashian steals her sister Chloe's
look yeah Bible it's a great look and
Coco did what sisters do full on trolled
her people but that's the fun of it the
fun started on Tuesday when the good
American founder shared these snapshots
rocking a gray bodysuit from Kim's skims
line we all want to be cute over here
okay fast forward to Wednesday Kim
posted her own pics in the same outfit
why not but gotta give credit where
credit's due the beauty Mogul did make
the look her own pairing it with darker
gray boots and a tiny silver clutch her
caption a simple hi I cannot believe it
that's when Coco hit up Kim's comment
section and playfully wrote oh okay well
I didn't look like this in mine ha
you're a [ __ ] you just gotta roll with
it but the drama surrounding the
Kardashian sisters wearing the same
outfits isn't new remember when Kim
accused Courtney of copying her style
she wants me to call Kenda because she
doesn't care about you and I
I don't know what you're talking about
I've never dressed like you oh is there
a fight no it's so ridiculous that we're
even having a conversation like this
because Kim and I have completely
different styles so even if we wear the
same designer we wear it in a completely
different way but Kim has offered to
style her siblings in the past even when
it was sorta unsolicited I think I can
just help Chloe have like more simple
style because her body really is the
accessory we gotta be chic
okay let's go hold on
don't rush me you're not like a real
stylist come on yes I am actually I
think she'll really appreciate this
but like wouldn't you be pissed if
someone took your bag and put whatever
their style was that they wanted you to
have but at the end of the day it's all
love between the ladies when it comes to
their looks it's such a beautiful thing
on the newest episode of the Kardashians
Khloe expressed her sisterly Envy a
couple of times and poked fun at that
rumor you know the one this humidity I
don't know how you're so perfect it's
wild you're such a beautiful girl that
you honestly think I don't know who your
parents are but they're not my parents
I'm really contemplating getting my
boobs done it's just something oh let's
do it together I just want Fuller like
when you see me in a bikini I don't have
like cleavage like my sisters have like
this
uh ample cleavage that I'm like I don't
know you just gotta see them without
this top on that's for another show
yeah save that for another show ladies
and keep rocking the fierce bits
[Music]